are we starting to see real signs that
stargate momentum is finally starting to
build
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so this is just going to be a quick
video based
a lot on speculation i have to admit but
on a story that was released a few hours
ago on msn.com now months ago you'll
remember i told you that when amazon was
ready to start building towards the
stargate and franchise being started
again we would start seeing mainstream
media news reports and little articles
like this one there's a link in the
description
now the article doesn't say anything too
dramatic the general
gist of the story is that hey guys do
you remember that stargate movie years
ago with james spader and kurt russell
wasn't that brilliant oh and they did a
tv show about it for 10 years following
it and oh it was great wasn't it now mgm
is owned by amazon maybe they'll do
something with this franchise sooner
rather than later that's the general
gist of the story
you'll remember though that months ago i
told you that this would happen that
building towards the green lighting of
the new series amazon would want to
build some information they would want
to put surveys out which we already know
they've done
and they would want to start you know
getting a few little press releases out
now i don't think for a second that this
story has been generated by accident msn
has not all of a sudden decided to go
should we do a story about stargate no
amazon
through msn has released this story it
is a little bit of a
poke to the general public do you
remember this they will then look at how
many clicks that gets how many comments
it gets if it gets shared if idiots like
me make videos about it
it will build information and data about
stargate that amazon will then use to
decide whether a new show is going to be
coming or not
if you do like the content by the way
guys please consider hitting the
subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you like him
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also
consider becoming a fully fledged side
track and hit the join button all these
little things they really help me to
keep the channel going in and in those
few little pennies that basically means
the wife will let me keep doing it
now
there is a little bit of a worry for me
i'm a little bit concerned this story is
based around the movie and not the
series particularly in only being three
or four weeks now until the sg-1 25th
anniversary
so
there was a story a couple of years ago
the mgm were seriously considering a
hard reboot of stargate and that that we
would actually see the original trilogy
that roland emerick and dean devlin
wrote made into a new series of films
and that would become the new franchise
so the difference between a hard reboot
and a soft reboot is that when you have
a hard reboot which happens all the time
in cinema you forget all about the
original product so sg-1 sg universe sga
didn't exist
we're just gonna start again and i have
done videos about talking about how that
that might actually not be a bad thing
overall because you've got a lot of
story there you don't have to worry
about a lot of can you don't have to
worry about you can create something new
but
that's what my head says but my heart
says dear god no if you do a hard reboot
i won't watch it i love sg-1 and sgu and
sg atlantis and you don't take my shows
away from me
but in the reality the cold light of day
i'd be torn and at the end of the day if
they created a decent stargate show i
wouldn't actually care if it was a hard
reboot or not because i can still go
back and sg-1 whenever i want it still
exists they're not deleting it but you
know
my heart says no hard reboot
this story focusing on the movie though
like i said makes me wonder if amazon is
still considering that now i have spoken
to a couple of the sources that i have
that work in and around mgm and working
in around amazon i all say
there is nothing going on
everything right now is on pause
amazon
looking at mgm's products everything
that mgm was planning to do over the
next year two years three years and they
are reviewing everything
there are no big decisions there is
really nothing going on they are
focusing on restructuring mgm and then
deciding what projects that mgm had in
the motion
to move forwards with
there is also though another concern
because it says i was told repeatedly
during over the last 12 months the
amazon were pushing mgm not to do a
reboot a hard reboot and that was
actually kind of backed up by roland
emerick because apparently there were
conversations about um a year or 18
months ago with roland denrick about
whether he would do a movie and he
basically said i don't really want to do
this because it was very clear to him
the tv audience was the audience that
mattered
and not the movie audience now i think
from that he meant that the audience for
sg-1 and sg universe and sg atlantis
were the focus they didn't want to and
amazon particularly didn't want to upset
that audience and doing a hard reboot
would upset them
so
they mgm had pretty much dismissed
the hard reboot idea because they
believed at the time that amazon didn't
want them to
now it seems though that actually mgm
may have misinterpreted a lot of what
they believed amazon thought they wanted
them to do or amazon actually have
thrown out everything they thought and
they're just starting again so we're
really at a point where anything might
be possible
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
you can consider becoming a fully fled
side tracker it's really supports the
channel hit the join button also there
is loads of merchandise including loads
of stargate t-shirts and things over at
cydashtrek.com again there's a link in
the description
so thanks very much guys and as always
please stay safe i'll see you soon
[Music]
you